hey I'm Hannah I'm the world's okay it's
mom but today I am watching my first
ever wine mom episode this series was
the very first type of content I
appeared in at BuzzFeed I was very
nervous and I think a lot of it is
probably gonna be mortifying but we'll
see maybe I'll pleasantly surprise
myself
okay wait I'm taking my bra
[Music]
fun fact I shot this series with Kevin
McShane who you probably know from drauf
it was just him and me alone in my house
to shoot these four years later we're
still working together very closely on
everything I do so this is the start of
a great working relationship
hi I'm Hannah I am your friendly
neighborhood wine mom oh hi didn't see
you there God why are we talking so
slowly I probably had a half a glass of
wine before this whole thing started
because I was really really nervous but
I look so young
BuzzFeed has aged me oh god this is
gonna be bad if you are like me you
believe that one glass of wine at 8 p.m.
makes you a better mom so pour yourself
one and let's talk about let's talk
about it really slowly hurry up girl
okay you know I'm ready here's why I'm
drinking tonight
my son is obsessed I did really drink
the wine in all of these episodes the
movie that's out right now called BFG
but somehow in his four-year-old brain
it's getting all scrambled he's telling
everyone
oh my auntie took me to see CPS over the
weekend and for those of you who don't
know what CPS stands for it is Child
Protective Services oh my gosh I
remember that happening that's really
embarrassing so have another sip of wine
I'm a good mom I swear kids are the most
beautiful creatures on the planet that
being said the first word that I think
about when I get to the point oh my god
the first word that comes to mind when I
think about parenting is shits the first
five or so years of your life you're
being [ __ ] on literally oh the first
five or so years of their life you're
been [ __ ] on literally and then from
there on out you get [ __ ] on emotionally
I have a four year old and a one year
old so I'm halfway now I have that
explains why I've aged so much dang it
just gets harder I thought it was hard
then well then when it finally comes
time to wipe your own butt my four year
old likes to sit and watch me actually
both of them like to sit and watch me
and then when I still shared some
privacy my four year old will go oh okay
he'll shoe the one-year-old out or go to
the door and sip
down okay dude whatever when they vomit
it's like they go out of their way to
vomit on something important so my son
did okay I was right because it it still
happens to this day okay good point old
Hannah like I am proud of you because I
see that you ate your whole dinner
I see broccoli in here I'll make some
veggies nice so next I can can't be
drunk because it's just one glass I'm
not even done so I'm just I was just
embarrassed and nervous when you have
kids you become accustomed to constant
noise it's like you kind of train
yourself just zone like getting your
boilers and finally get your silence
it's terrifying something terrible is
happening there's poop on the walls for
sure there's crayon on something
somewhere reading my lipstick it's a one
time it was silent and my son was in the
bathroom dunking the bath towels into
the toilet and then sucking on them why
would you do that are you thirsty which
son was that I didn't specify I don't
remember that I think I blocked it from
my memory Oh God
girls slow down I cannot believe I drink
on camera kids are so expensive swim
lessons there's new shoes every other
week their feet grow so fast I they only
get more expensive hobbies they just
like take it they can take all your
money and then they don't even
appreciate it like my son I make him his
organic bread turkey sandwich he'll ask
for the crust betrayed oh yeah the
morning I cut the crust off then all of
a sudden he decided in that time I was
cutting the crust that he doesn't want
the crust cut off anymore so I served
him the sandwich and he's like oh my god
mom meltdown I'm talking about Jackson
in this one and he is my easy kid oh man
I had no idea what was coming I cannot
believe I even had the audacity to
complain you can't win and finally why
your child is going to ask why - every
mundane little thing you say that grass
is green Wow
realize how little you know about the
world I look so different why was this
like hugely pregnant right now you have
this opportunity and this chance to make
something beautiful it's basically like
learning from your life and making
something better for somebody else I
can't think of something that holds any
more meaning than that all I can hope is
that I don't [ __ ] it up I'm tearing up
one glass of wine in me and I'm like
blubbering all the time that's just how
it works I can have no glasses of wine
and cry at the drop of a hat you can
show me a picture of a puppy and I will
cry also I remember thinking like oh I
have blue hair and I'm a mom I gotta be
edgy and so I cursed in this and you can
see in the watery eyes deep down I've
always been a wuss in a snap and I just
finally embraced it until next time I'm
Hannah your neighbourhood wine mom and
I'll see you later you don't want to see
me like this
go the verb I burped in every episode to
this day it still blows my mind that
anybody watches anything that I'm an
when we went in to shoot that video I
had no expectations I just thought you
know I'll try my best
it's all just very very real um - all
the curse things I would tell old Hannah
just just brace yourself you think it's
tough now just wait until your youngest
starts to talk
[Music]